louder with cryder studios is protected
exclusively by walther
and hopper
i could have got more i could have got
more
i don't know if i just i could have got
more steven
1500 people will be filling the
university of michigan power center
because of your show look at them
if i'd have gotten hill auditorium i
throw away
so many names on a waiting list you have
no idea
if i'd have just pushed for hill of the
tory the school would never let you have
the hill auditorium because of the
things you did
i should have pushed hard you pushed as
hard as you could i know i know it's 3
900 seats but
maybe if i could have showed them the
overflow
this screen this few of these 10 boys in
their college door
10 more people that would have been 10
more people
this family watching right now on the
roku
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
october 25th spooktacular um may be sold
out
but you can still sign up now for the
secret overflow room and the block party
mug club secret after-party details to
follow
do so much more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
whoa we've got some moves that's called
the make our third chairsman
the men hodgepods incredibly
uncomfortable right off the bat how are
you boys
it was pretty sexy man put the money
away guys
we have we have razor fist on the show
today really excited we're going to have
daniel cormier
he had to move last second we'll have
him on i think next week also with like
jordan peterson it's going to be a crazy
apparently you can do that when you're
the toughest guy in the world when he
can beat you up yeah we say nothing
uh what is hodgetwinstour.com yeah
heartstringstour.com and you have dates
coming up soon
dates we've got plenty of dates in texas
and florida they also had half a beer so
you know they're
done yeah for them i thought my eyes are
like this new show open by the way and
yes the u of m
u of m show is happening october 25th
you might even add a second show so
don't not book it because it's
sold out uh quarter black garrett
producing uh thank you black
g morgan junior what's the wine of the
day we got t-vine mix blacks
is it t or is it wine next blacks is it
t or t
vine see this is why people think you're
affected uh
question of the day it was special so
we'll be talking later about today's
leftist hate mob i know
that every time we use the word mob the
hajj ones get jumping
see uh
do you think the heads of dnc the media
are just blatantly encouraging
endorsing mob rule now or are you still
like in the woods boom
bertie's man camp is it really any
equivalency at this point genuinely
i want to know uh what are we that later
you guys have been pretty safe though
yeah yeah everywhere you go what's funny
is you know if i get recognized
it's like either people really like me
or hate me with you guys sometimes it's
just a novelty because you're like oh
two black twins
tacos and i remember the one guy was a
real fan he was like oh man mentioned
specific and then a girl was just like
oh i know you
yeah it's always that uh expression yeah
the cream pie twins
no no no no no double maintenance sounds
censored right off the bat but the guy
was a big fan i remember what he
referenced
okay listen leading the news um
president trump's meeting with kanye
west
didn't exactly go as planned uh
this comes from the hill possibly the
best quote ever that we've had in this
show
the rap star launched into a monologue
touching on mental health the prison
system
and improving life for african-americans
in inner cities you need it really was a
breakdown
if you watch the monologue it's a shame
too the two have actually been really
excited about the
white house sleepover for some time now
la
la la wait till i see kanye tonight
i had a dream of a sleepover with donald
watch netflix maybe eat some tacos
he told me he was gonna be so dope
though me
grabbing entrance by the truth i wish
everybody chill man i ain't one of the
clintons i ain't have nobody killed man
i pissed pelosi off of funsies make
america great in our onesies
i don't know what happened there exactly
it seems like you know what if that's
what it seems like it makes sense that
they
they they went off the rails in a pod
right i love how when when they were
inviting him over to like they're gonna
talk about manufacturing resurgence
violence
and prisons and i'm like you through
manufacturing resurgence yeah
and not talk about violence in prison
exactly really kanye knows a lot about
manufacturing i want popcorn with your
white popcorn
yeah just passionate every time
last name corn first name pop cut okay
was that good my toronto friends
[Laughter]
gosh drake buttersoft from toronto was
he the sprite guy that you used to
in the movie yeah yeah yeah oh my god
the whitest way to know him was that the
sprite guy hey was that the guy selling
the soda pop
all right another trump news alec
baldwin claims that ever since he's
played trump black people
love me his direct quote here's another
direction he says i think it's because
they're most afraid of trump
i'm not going to paint every
african-american person with the same
brush and then he does
but a significant number of them are
sitting there going this is going to be
bad for black folks
um funny enough i like baldwin for his
voicemails i don't give a damn that
you're 12 years old whether you're a
child
whether your mother is a thoughtless
pain in the ass who doesn't care about
what you do as far as i'm concerned
you have humiliated me for the last time
of this phone
i you know what's funny is he blames the
daughters
for homage i mean that's really not fair
i get the daughters of pain in the ass
but yeah
and your mom's a [ __ ] why do you gotta
throw that in there
you know apparently rating a 12 year old
since playing trump black people love
him hodge twins
i don't think so i think it's just
because he's cooning
wait how does a white guy do this wait
what yeah he's the first man he's just
it's amazing white people are cooling
for black folks now
i got bad news yeah black people
don't like you man they're not big fans
of
reruns of 30 rock that's not that's not
yeah a lot of people don't like donald
trump because these are
because they're racist black people are
racist
they don't like your white ass knees but
you get but you guys did say you did
tell me that that
some black people are afraid of trump
you thought nah
they just they just don't understand
them they don't understand he's missing
i don't think they really care about him
or politics no it's the economy right
i mean would you say that's true like if
they're doing well they're going to be
like i don't care wait a while
wait a while oh come on it really it
really depends on how
um cnn proceeds everything and that's
what also yeah
okay the sources are bad it's not their
fault i didn't really think that black
people were watching cnn
yeah that's who's watching the black
folks mama used to watch it all the time
really yeah she'll watch that andy
griffith will come on
and then she look at red fox and then
re-wrap it in son yeah
that's when you guys leave just like
every stereotype possibly
i'm watching jefferson's then you leave
and she goes
here's another what about uh how local
government works for you the houston
city council actually found a new
loophole to prevent a sex
robot brothel from dangerous so let me
explain this too because the story might
seem a little tough
the city council actually expanded its
definition of an arcade device
okay which are already barred from
operating within 1500 feet of churches
schools daycares parks residential
neighborhoods
so let me clarify this they're actually
they're classifying creepy sex
robots as arcade machines now because
those
are apparently easier to regulate oh man
you can crack down those which makes
sense actually given when you consider
what some people do with the uh with
their
well hey there you go hey come on get
out of come on
every day at least twice i've been sex
with eight machines
i want to go play that's the last time
that's the last time
those things look so you said that last
time that's the last time we let him
have sex with our arcade machine
did you guys ever play the hot shot like
the basketball hot shot deal in the
arcades but get those games i want to
play the game he was yeah exactly
my time apparently was misplaced i was
really good at that i should have been
good at the other games also is it odd
that uh
i have a walther on the desk but use a
2x4 with nails no because i'm not the
liability i don't want to lose them as a
sponsor
oh speaking of city councils things
doing that they're doing weird stuff uh
detroit now
is there areas of detroit being
designated as no spanking zones
this comes from detroit yeah they passed
a resolution to discourage corporal
punishment
that makes sense by creating hit free
zones in at least 10
public areas with signs that actually
specify that so
good to see detroit on on track towards
solutions yeah
hey how about not disciplining your
children
no shooting stones on the right track
was it yeah it's no shooting zones
that would be great right yeah that's
what i would have came up with but i
don't know here's
here how about this detroit no spain if
you have a dad take it as a win
let's go with that let's not get picky
at this point all right detroit like
maybe he has a couple too many comes
home starts swat that's fine
he's you're lucky to have him in your
life
we need more consequences not less
consequences in these situations beat
tan their hide you guys got weapons
lord you are so uncomfortable around
black people what did i say
you guys got whoopings right didn't
y'all get weapons
he starts talking like steve harvey i
wouldn't call them weapons that was his
beatings
straight lashes see i wasn't trying to
say that
but you did daddy give us lashes
yeah yeah oh yeah did they got the belt
make you go get your own switch oh the
switch
every time i try to defend you from
gerald's sort of assuming something that
stereotype that's right
you fulfill it i remember one day these
little kids was throwing rocks at cars
and we hit this guy's car nut it was a
white man
he was pissed he goes
and talks to my daddy i'm running away
from daddy for like days he finally got
us
oh my god he said i'm going to kill you
boy two states away
he beat us back he beat us real bad i
blacked out man woke up he was still
hitting me
i learned a valuable lesson though don't
throw rocks at cars no don't throw rocks
at a white man's car
no don't get caught throwing rocks at
cars thank you a real lesson
yeah god you know what i did the exact
same thing
except it was a pudding packs well
that's funny i used to love them lobbed
them from
atop the bridge yeah one time a bus
driver got out and kicked my friend's
ass
he stopped his route he just stopped he
came out
before a song there's a french canadian
[Music]
i understand
true story that's awesome uh hey by the
way did everyone know that it was
national coming out day oh
today my day if you've been if you've
been anywhere is this
that that makes sense i'm engaged to a
woman
now it makes sense what's the emphasis
he's queer as folk as ron paul puts it
yeah i'm coming out i'm transracial
i'm going about a white man crept in the
nigga's body
so how does that even happen well rachel
she paved the way for a lot of stuff
she did trendsetters did you watch that
the documentary that rachel dolezal
documented oh man i got to catch that
one
one beer by the way my eyes are up here
they're looking at the camera
like dustin hoffman and hook with the
clocks they're like
i can't handle it so national coming out
there was trending everywhere and
celebrate of course facebook unveiled a
new
coming out feature coming out feature i
think was a came out fishing
it was hard to read from the headlines
so let me read exactly this comes from
mdc
for the lgbtq community facebook is a
way for you to come out
oh good visibility is so important
because it changes hearts and minds
about being lgbtq
when friends and family see us living
our true selves so actually here's a
look at uh one of the coming out
features they're uh their emojis
okay which makes sense but facebook went
a step further in an ill-advised spirit
of balanced
uh unfortunately simultaneously
unveiling the drag them behind a truck
feature which was not received very
well oh dear god yeah that was um by the
way just for
you know we obviously we use a joke
because you know why not but uh
it's only happened a handful of times
gave you being dried behind a truck
when people talk about hangings
lynchings those those happened all the
time yeah right
yeah the gays behind the truck it was
like twice it was like at a m in one
other time
and the one it was just a gay guy roller
it was a fish tailing accident
how did this turn into a hate crime i
didn't know she was lesbian
i wouldn't have done it just trying to
have fun that was it was it was an
accident now the
it happened the other time it was pretty
homophobic they knew what they were
doing yeah
there were no rollerblades involved
a time to kill you she's that that movie
is rough
you're seeing free carly what freak time
to kill
they're with me you're not with me i
just literally picked up on the one
thing where you could have an excuse to
do a black voice with black people in
the studio was that black boys yeah
yeah that's what happened it was like
fruit
freaking i was doing it like a mob
chance yeah yeah yeah
this is why black people don't become
republican some because of the idea is
because people like you
hey listen hodge twins i'm so glad to
see some black twins tell the truth for
once
we're gonna go have a beer after this
and you're not invited i mean that in a
good way you can't not unless you want
them vomiting in the kitchen so you're
gonna have a 40 that's what you want to
say
no i said a beer i don't think you'd be
capable of a 40
yeah i don't think so neither 40s are
banned you know why they were used as
weapons
what did you know that's not yeah girthy
yeah we were trying to get a 40 at one
point
this was in missouri anyways and these
the the clerk said no they're banned
because people would take them
drink them and then break them and stab
the next guy for the rest of his 40.
blame the black people that's the black
people started that right
oh second i didn't mention d c no hold
on they copy paste that
that's what we call projecting because i
didn't say black anything
i did you did you did yeah it's him only
black people drink forties because there
was an ad once with billy dee williams
you guys need to you know what are you
you're caught in chaffed billy dee
williams what's happening
coat 45 does it every time
you see those commercials you just did
it again i did chris rock what
not rocco what's his name now he's just
picking random black guys little black
billy williams chris rock uh martin
luther king i don't know
it was like a movie no looking like i
like denzel washington
he's a good actor isn't he boys
i'm uncomfortable for you you i think
you doth protest too
finally and then we have another story
to get to before we get to the leftist
mob and uh this never happens news five
girls falsely accused a man of a
sexual assault boy really just because i
didn't like him never yeah what
yeah the actual story the boy's parents
say he was forced to endure the loss of
his liberty and other damages
until several of the girls reluctantly
admitted that their accusations were
false they're now suing
uh the girls in the school district this
and this is the problem with the metoo
movement this is what we were talking
we've been talking about this entire
time when people say you're a guy you
have no id you have nothing to fear
there is plenty to fear because of
exactly this
and if the girls hadn't admitted it they
probably wouldn't have caught them it's
become the modern day equivalent
of lynching and it's in some cases it's
just an actual one
now are you ready mr coffee
can you leave the light on boss
i get a little scared being falsely
accused
[Music]
i'm watching both of you one of you
finds it hilarious one is like
we made some mistakes how many beers did
we have
man why was your lips so pink i don't
know i told him that lip sticking
wasn't necessary
there are two black people i know of in
human history to go on blackface
one was the aforementioned drake yeah
but he did it as a statement you just
did it for funny
[Laughter]
oh my god seriously what do you think do
you think black people care if you're
like you're black
oh you're winning darker than you really
are oh definitely getting the kuna to
you
[Laughter]
crucified hanging on the cross
excommunicated for sure well you know if
you had second thoughts you only had 45
minutes while they applied them income
apparently put it on i still have it on
my hand
i was drugged i didn't do it what's that
movie um
that the actor did um he was he did
black tropic thunder
oh yeah yeah he should have got a camera
award for that
yeah i shot with a black girl an
ethiopian girl and she i remember she
thought it was hysterical it was i don't
know
you know what's funny i remember going
home with her and uh no no with her
family it's just her family you know
this girl this was a girl who makeout
raped me
uh i was like long story short
yeah i feel so bad i was trying i was
trying to exhibit self-control at that
period of my life because it was
difficult and it's just and then she was
just like ah
and i was like oh okay rosario doesn't
look alike i hate this jungle fever
i just i don't know what that even means
oh yeah oh yeah
cultural differences cultural
differences any points tonight
no yeah i do point you because i'm not
the one going like hey boys you wanna
y'all wanna 40. see
that's what he's doing i would never say
it like that
his show prep was wearing extra wide
suits watching kings of comedy
that's steve harvey so i remember i went
she went home with me with i went home
with her family i know this is going to
be taking i went home her mom was there
at that point dropping her off and her
sisters and her dad
and she said this is a movie that we saw
and her mom said isn't that the movie
with she didn't she didn't have it all
she was ethiopian it sounded i don't i i
couldn't even describe the accent
uh but not what we would picture is
black and she said isn't that the one
where the guy went in blackface like she
was maybe kind of offended
and then the girlfriend woman said no
mom it was just that was the whole joke
whether yeah
and she said oh oh and she laughed that
was mine was explained to her by her
daughter and that was it wait people get
mad about this
apparent well yeah they oh you ever see
you have you ever seen when they uh they
censored on on on air
no no you know what's going on it was a
backlash from it really yeah
well not only do they try and track
blura's face but that doesn't work they
actually
never go never go full [ __ ] they
change oh yeah like change that never go
full
stupid it's one of those things it
doesn't make any sense exactly
i missed that one the worst one is uh
sam jackson on the snakes in a plane
it's like
i am tired of these motherflipping
snakes on this twisted tied up plane
the worst one is upka mr falcon
which is not really fair because then a
kid is not going to know what the actual
word means no no he's going to call
someone mr falcon and get in trouble or
he's going to be like on his honeymoon
like i'm i'm falconing really
you know we're going to go okay we're
going to go to falcon town
[Laughter]
that's a sort of important topic the
dive in i guess people are calling it
dive and now it's what
they call these sort of topics where you
explore them so during the kavanaugh
hearings
obviously democrats they uh for those
who don't know doc's senators senator
they sent rice to the pentagon
white powder to ted cruz's office angry
of course angry mobs into congressional
offices and by the way don't forget
the absolutely insane mobs we're not
supposed to use this word trying to
break down the supreme court door
[Applause]
try to do something yeah exactly you
know they planned ahead they're like
okay listen riff
if if this guy gets confirmed we've got
option a or option b because we need
several months to muster the
digger we need a little protein we need
to get some protein in our diets at the
gym
they're just like they're simultaneously
force-feeding spirulina
is there b12 in this their hands are
bouncing off the door when they hit b12
analog it's not real ah but they look
like real bad actors to me
when you say false flag so um good news
i think here
is that uh i think i i hope this and i
wonder what you guys think would it
the gop hopefully learned that it's it's
futile it's it's futile to trying to
piece
out that's what i'm talking about a lot
i don't agree with this idea of unity of
kumbaya of holding hands with people who
you can't
good example uh when people talk about
kavanaugh some people said he should
step
down you know he should he should step
down if confirmed because uh maybe it
could be a great
time for healing and you know would you
want to heal with the person who just
accused you of rape right
let alone the person who accused you of
gang rape right or the person who sent
white powder to your office where do you
find common ground
that's why i draw the line between rape
and gang rape yes
that's where you draw the line that's
why i draw a line hardline
hard pass should be drawn probably
before we before we get to the arcade
machine
hopefully the gop and you let me know
what you think they've learned i mean
look even even lindsey graham grew a
fuzzy pair
if you don't like me working with
president trump to make the world a
better place i don't give a sh
[Laughter]
oh my gosh lindsey graham yeah golden
graham a lot of column
2.0 now gram 2.0 because they're one
like hey hey where did you find that
package you know it's but the thing is
it's it's actually
bloomberg 2.0 i think yeah it really is
hopefully they've don't appease
and if you're going to be unified be
unified and politically resisting the
left yeah they have
how can you possibly unify with somebody
who has no intention of compromising
with you whatsoever right
the gop i think what lindsey graham has
tapped into is that people get
frustrated and they want you to stand
for principle and show some balls
and he did and people were like finally
well you know even removing this idea of
standing for principle let's even remove
that idea they just want a man to show
some balls
not in a park not with a trench coat
they want you to show the skill
the skill of exhibiting ball like
behavior
i'm glad you delineated the two because
i was about to head out
mine they're not even symmetrical
um so here's the thing i think you know
we've covered leftist violence before i
think you were on the show
every time someone's on the show there's
some sort of outburst of left no it's
hard to narrow down
the difference is that the the left is
now embracing it and this is where i
think it changes i don't think there's
any there's no virtue in finding common
ground with people
who are endorsing and embracing mob rule
democrats lost and so now they're
choosing to stir the pot
and to get people to do what you just
saw if you think by the way's just
happening randomly okay let's go to
let's go through a timeline
endorsement number one it came a little
while ago from maxine waters sorry about
this
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant
in a
[Applause]
the new kkk it's like the reverse kkk is
she like you're hillary clinton
or does no one really think about her
what was that
one beer one beer and it wasn't even
called 45 i think it was fat tire
this is why this is white person beer
i'm like it's five percent
every time i see her i think of james
brown for some reason
i think a little richard actually i
actually was
dropping down uh what's the place in l.a
where you bring your mic closer to your
face i know you're drunk but you know
we can't hear you okay remember was
driving down skid row
yeah saw a couple of them saw a couple
cranes look just like
that wouldn't be a bad stick actually
maxine waters next time she's on stage
can't go on
can't go on crazy [ __ ]
yeah one of them looked at him hey hey
you wanna get sucked off
oh gosh
that's a pertinent detail
i don't know what you're saying that's
an older clip maybe she's just senile
vaccine waters
okay granted at least that but what
about what about
photo negative ned flanders let's see
what eric holder has to say
but michelle says that you know when
they go low
we go higher
when they go low we kick
listen to the clap listen to the
audience there so a couple things that
are really telling first off is the
audience clapping
right that was uh that was shirley uh it
was charade remember when um
when andrew breitbart talked about the
naacp and she talked about how she
didn't help the white farmer everyone
got on him for selectively editing it
because later on down the line she said
no no i learned that i shouldn't be
racist but the thing is the naacp crowd
clapped 10 minutes before that they just
heard racist stuff like
a couple of things there first off the
audience is clapping secondly
uh eric holder sounds remarkably like
every single black comedian's white guy
voice
yeah it sounds like richard pryor would
be like oh when they go low
we kick them harder they used to be what
you get made fun of in the movies
exactly but he specifically used the
michelle
just you know that's from her statement
right when they go low we go high he
used her statement
for a 180 saying no this is he defines
the new democratic party he wants you to
know
don't go high kick them harder but not
not above
shin height because i can't kick that
high because i haven't done my
i haven't done my yoga we're completely
out of ideas the ideas that we have
right now are completely bankrupt and so
we have to have mob
rule that's the new democratic party
exactly um did it
was it the lighting or does he have like
three mustaches on his face
here he has two mustaches come on then
there is something else that crawled up
there we haven't figured it out it looks
like a light-skinned walrus
[Laughter]
it lost a lot of weight this has evolved
into ad hominems
cut which i find both offensive and
unnecessary and here's what i know
people going to say well what about
trump saying i get it out of here back
there we used to punch him with the face
right okay i unders
donald trump says stupid crap he said
some stupid but there is a
huge difference between saying get him
out of here at a protester
at a rally on your campaign trail and
the current democratic leadership
coordinating calls for harassment
against republicans across the board in
public spaces before we move on by the
way hit the notification bell because
apparently subscriptions don't mean
anything on youtube
and uh join my club if you want the
daily show every single day annually 69
for students veterans active military
rate us on itunes subscribe if you want
to listen on the go and i'm on instagram
at lotto with crowder okay you want to
go to another endorsement
look at that that's like eat your heart
out ben shapiro just not on saturday
because he can't do mental labor
hillary clinton endorsement number three
you cannot be civil
with a political party that wants to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
that's why i believe
if we are fortunate enough to win back
the house and or the senate that's when
civility can start again
you can't you first off that's daddy you
cannot
be civil with the party that okay you
don't stand you collapse
secondly what do you i love
see this is what i like having here
didn't you just you just said didn't you
steal some money from haiti
a bunch of money from videos hey every
time i see that woman man i get
shrinkage
[Laughter]
no that's just called that's a natural
reaction look they're playing with fire
here though
in the history of creating mobs they
tend to turn on everybody so you have to
remember this is like yeah you know if
you're uh what is that
i think cersei lannister when she
created the sparrows um
and thank you i don't i don't know what
you're talking about you don't watch you
don't
watch the no but when we said torch i
was thinking kill the beast
kill a dick and they turn on him game of
thrones she creates this mob of people
that end up turning on her and she has
to do that walk of shame down like this
is what's going to happen to the dems
they're going to create this antifa mob
and they're going to be like all right
we're going to kick you out two days
sorry bye
it's like two seconds from turning
around yeah yeah that intellect is not
real uh
yeah they came here but they got small
brains man
that's this is that that that all right
i'll allow it
when people say oh that's why i said to
both parties man there's not a single
republican group out there
calling for the pulling of pulling
people out of their vehicles
and beating them up did you see the
portland video yeah did you see the
stuff that's crazy
grab an old man pull them out do you
have any idea what would happen
if if two white guys pulled an old black
woman or man out of a car oh my
god oh my god and by the way we would
all be rightfully pissed
yeah because white people don't really
have a loyalty to white people we're
like wow that guy's a dick you know we
don't have that camaraderie
i'm not gonna go stand in an
intersection and make cars turn right
when they want to go straight
no that's that's power to the people
right there
absolutely by the way here's a bonus
okay another media cover the democrats
now
they're endorsing mob rule but cnn has
said your mom's favorite network
apparently
we're not allowed to they actually refer
to it as the
m-m not an m-word seriously
i believe it's the overreaction of the
left when you see people like ted cruz
getting chased out of restaurants by a
mob
oh you're not going to use the mod oh
it's it's totally a mob
it is without a doubt there's no other
word for it
brook baldwin by the way she was also
offended at the word boobs remember that
guy said boobs she's like we don't allow
that kind of talk on this show
like breasts or boobs it's not even
really women say
i don't think i've ever heard my wife
refer to them as anything other than
boobs breast is in the bible it's fine
yeah yeah but use that time i don't
think boobs are in the bible
oh it's not like in the song no but
that's below that i feel like that's
like
less yeah you can't say titties anymore
not on brooke baldwin's show i can't
believe she said that about mob what
what's the offensive thing about it no
no again they don't want to say because
now they're trying to say remember when
they try to say you're calling barack
obama be
a socialist because he can't use the
n-word now they're saying oh well you're
calling them the m-word because you
didn't really
what what do you what what would you
call that in front of this
let's look at the definition of mob from
merriam-webster granted you know white
supremacist conspiracy but let's just go
with it for this moment
mob a large and disorderly crowd of
people especially one bent on riotous or
destructive action okay hold on let's
check back in to see what you have
the alleged m word in question would fit
this definition
yeah that's a mob it's a vegan mob but
it's a mob yeah it's weak but it's not
it seems pretty cut and dry
and this is this is really what what
bothers me and i've seen some people on
the right and i don't want to
i never want to call anybody out who i
think can do some some good and change
some minds
but there have been some people who
folks have been disappointed in um
i'm waiting to see what transpires but i
have always disagreed with this idea of
common ground you've heard me say this
people come on the show will match
intensity i believe in being civil with
people
right but i don't believe in finding
agreement on a lie
and we're at the point i there i can
have no unity with these people
what common ground are we going to have
and by the way here's something more
important whether you feel that way or
not some people like well
i want to find common ground first off i
think you're a pansy
secondly ask any single member of
special forces police ask any
psychologist about the mob mentality and
how to deal
all of them will tell you when there is
a mob there is something that happens
psychologically
people cease to be individuals it is its
own
functioning organism it is an amoeba
that you cannot rationalize with
you have to get away and we've seen this
with changed my mind we've seen it where
we've gone out
we've had someone sit down we've had a
conversation and it's been
and everyone else goes oh okay but when
one person sits down and starts yelling
you don't know who brett kavanaugh is
vagina whatever it is
then all of a sudden everyone starts
yelling yeah get off this campus we hate
you and you're like oh my gosh i'm gonna
get stabbed by someone who doesn't even
know how to handle a knife yeah
people will do things in a mob they
would never do as individuals ever
exactly because they're in a mob that's
why they're so
dangerous and we have to not let this
happen i learned that in
a kid's book sorry we should we've been
saying all some you guys call them gangs
yes that's what's going on in chicago
yeah
it's the mob mentality i mean there's
study after study after study that's
been done on this it's a horrible thing
and yet they're pushing it and this is
what bothers me when people on the right
try to say well let's find common ground
how with a mob do do me don't actually
do this
but think of yourself in the middle
of a mob of an actual one think of
yourself in the middle of uh think of
yourself in the
in your car right and you're in your
camry when they open your door and drag
you out and start beating you up and
think of yourself going like
hey hey hey where can we find common
ground guys
are you just the fringe who who cares
because the fringe that you see
endorsed by hillary clinton eric holder
uh maxine waters they certainly haven't
been disavowed by anyone and by the way
no republicans and i'm not a republican
but
when we're talking about republicans and
democrats here no republicans
have done this no conservatives are out
there doing this the left is doing this
in
shifts have you seen it's really oak
okay i've been i've been uh i've been uh
blocking this uh this corner here for
about four hours can you
can you take but it's like punching in
the the sheep dog and the sheep and in
that bugs bunny like all right
punch in beat an innocent protester hope
it's not jocko driving up in the car
it is unbelievable to me and i don't
think there's
anything uh i don't think there's
anything virtuous about finding common
ground with them i don't think there's
anything practical about trying to find
common ground with these people and i
don't think there's anything productive
in trying to feign common ground with
these people when you have
every single member of the dnc who's in
a position of authority endorsing them
when you just say one second you're
endorsing the mob they go ah
we're starting to throw the m word
around a little flippantly here
shut up shut up i've had okay we're
gonna have a razor fist
after the break and hodge twins are
[Music]
great
[Music]
now as you can probably guess mr coffee
is most certainly gonna fry
and that's only because we outlawed
hanging but six years ago
but he'll still get to enjoy his last
meal of his favorite chatter on this
mug or from this mug
louderwoodcrowder.com
he likes it for as much longer as he has
is
that's a giant picard song and i always
wondered why he was having to tell
everyone to cheer up
i don't know maybe it's it's sad in
space yeah i think it's because lavar
burton realized that he wasn't gay
our next guest uh really happy to have
him on the program you know
on the youtube the rage-aholic is the
channel you can follow him on the
twitter at
resort with a zero yeah i have to
specify because he wants to make my job
hard
fist uh you know mr fist how are you sir
i'm doing fantastic uh it's it's cool
enough here that i can wear my leather
regalia
i would have worn it last time but you
know it was monsoon it was phoenix and i
didn't feel like reverting back to a
liquid state
do you get recognized in the street if
you're not wearing your leather jacket
and gla
or glasses oh yeah i can i can go full
normie you'd be surprised really oh yeah
you'd be you'd be shocked at how normal
i can look see i feel like i'd be able
to pick you up more easily even in
costume at a furry convention than
without
your garb
[Laughter]
this is true and since i can't really
wear the leather most of the year you
know
i don't know i figured you just went
with it i thought it was a thing that
you just committed one i'm losing
respect for you as we're going with the
interview uh
let me let me let me ask you this i know
you've talked you've talked about this
quite a bit you and i obviously are in
the same boat we just talked about this
with the hodge twins
it's the m word now this has been kind
of what's been going on this week
the the the portland antifa beating
people out of their car
um what do you think about the current
state of america people are acting as
though this is the first time we've been
divided
i kind of i kind of appreciate that just
now we can see them for what they are
now exactly it's been it's been the rule
of the day since i mean
it's hard to sell this on being trump's
fault when it was happening when obama
was president as well
this is true but my favorite thing about
it is you know they're trying to sell
this glorified tism tantrum
as like an act of insurgent heroism yes
like
yeah i i threw a jar of piss on a 75
year old
man i mildly disagree with politically
you know oh my
hunger strike as an act of protest
meanwhile she's like 400 pounds fully
nude
yes like no sweetie if i need an act of
heroism i'll ask you to do a jumping
jack
yeah no i well listen when you talk
about as though it's this act of sort of
heroism
there are these insurgents i mean they
see it that way because uh they also see
the taliban
uh taliban as as heroic insurgents so
this isn't that far of a stretch
right speaking of the chance by the way
can we maybe hit the
refresh button on those every 50 years
or so
like this is supposed to be the party of
elevated intellectuals and the best they
can come up with for the better part of
a century is uh heihei
and ho ho i know i know okay thank you
someone else i'm like oh did he just
create a rhyme at all
i mean you know you're supposed to be
the party of hip and now they've lost
kanye but you've got all the other ones
right you know what you tricked click
yes right anything i don't know how
about here's something how about hey hey
no no and then just like something you
don't like
you know exactly exactly it's a movie
either way
either way hit that refresh button like
this chant is old enough to remember
biden's first set of hair plugs
like and and what part of protesting
like five-year-olds
got you trump are they not understanding
exactly
well you know that's a good point that
you bring up i know you said you have a
uh we talked about a video i think on
the sort of blue wave as it's been
described
uh coming up what's your thought on this
right now people are predicting
potentially a blue wave
um obviously like you said this is the
same behavior that got us trump and do
you think the the sort of kavanaugh the
post-kavanaugh america
the kavanaugh effect as it were uh has
affected the blue wave maybe maybe
stunted a little bit
that's the thing i mean it's it's
falling to predict anything because
anything could change
any day if we've learned anything over
the last two years
right but if if the polls are any
indication that kavanaugh should fit is
going over like hillary on a stair
master you know what i mean
it's not working out so well uh cinema
was leading
uh here in arizona preston cinema was
leading and now she's behind
by six after throwing in with the
kavanaugh guys
so it's not exactly they're trying to
sell this sort of lord of the rings
fantasy of the blue wave but
here's the thing about the internet it
never forgets and i was going back like
just out of curiosity
go back and read almost any article from
before donald trump became president and
the democrats
were absolutely apoplectic at the
prospect of the 2018 midterms
right you know like the math is the math
republicans are only defending eight
seats in the midterms democrats
are defending nearly three times that 25
seats
and five of those are in blood red
states with incumbents
who tied their political careers to the
fortunes of the uh uss
clindenberg so that's
i don't see how that's going to work out
for them blue wave once yeah well and
also 25 of those seats are
are also double seats because many of
them are democrats
um now we talked about the stairmaster
we're going back to fat jokes you
started you you opened this can
you wanted to play this game i'm playing
with you uh
my speaking of hillary i love you have
hillary out there yesterday saying uh
there'll be no civility until she's back
in power
right i mean like i mean at one point do
you just consider this a threat
it's like i will i will be violent until
i get what i want
oh can we can we sell the locker up
t-shirts now or is that considered
domestic terrorist no kidding
no kidding no no sweetie i think we call
that a syntax discrepancy until you're
in power there can be no senility
yeah that's how that works well it's
always i don't it's always hard to know
where she's coming from because it just
keeps stabbing her with a diazepam she
can't get a word in edgewise
did you see did you see the secret
service prop and that uh
sea hag up with rebar while she was
having yet another hacking fit last
weekend
yeah like you can you believe they
sincerely tried to sell us on this woman
being like a robust biological specimen
yeah the election remember it was in new
york they said you know it was hot out
today we're like well okay what about
the other 364 days this year
there's the she's shuffling around in
her chairman mal mumu you know hacking
up
the tires there's a portrait of health
and like two years later this drunken
dingbat still hacking away like you know
doc cabernet like what do you even have
what does this woman have two years
later like disco fever didn't last as
long
and it's just it's just as toxic i
believe no i
i do i don't know what i remember they
stabbed with a diazepam pen and everyone
was like that's a conspiracy
well that's actually not really a
conspiracy by the way it's not like it
wasn't even that
subtle like they're i talked about this
with in the pitch they were stabbing her
like uh like russell crowe with that
kind of tall guy with the weird teeth
and three tend to yuma you know they
wake up and he's by the fireplace
everybody's just going into town and
you're like he's got the handcuffs on
how can he stab with such velocity
that's what they're doing with this lady
and this is it is
one thing though for people to act this
way right like you said under obama
under um
and even under trump initially but a lot
of the democrats themselves
kind of tried to act like they weren't
throwing their lot in with antifa now
they're just saying
yeah yeah they are i mean we just we
just had uh uh uh
eric holder talking about photo negative
ned flanders we just had him talking
about it
maxine waters of course we have uh
hillary clinton
i mean is it obama didn't do that
at least he hid it right exactly
that's that's the thing although you do
have to say
like and he also displayed a little bit
of shame
too you know like after the after the
blm stuff
it was so bad even obama's hair didn't
want to be black
and and like but hillary's like yeah
antifa we got a grassroots movement
finally she's coming with it she's
coming in with a perm
does this work is this still i know the
disco fever's gone but i thought i had a
pass with my viral
i um i don't um i don't like these
people
the kavanaugh stuff too has kind of
emboldened them
because now they can make it about
reproductive rights right you know
like because you know now you got pelosi
flipping about flipping out about
roe v wade and so forth like
really pelosi in authority the last time
this woman had a period the word
cretaceous was in front of it
suddenly she's like the grand vizier of
vaginas
like i don't know take a long look at
that facelift does that look like a
person you'd like handling your medical
care
no no i don't imagine i don't even think
i would i would let her handle like
i wouldn't even let her watch my
five-year-old on the weekend if she were
my mother
i wouldn't if only because it would
scare the five-year-old even if you're
really really nice like
let's say on the inside she weren't
nancy pelosi just because of the outside
of like
you're scaring the kids and i'm gonna
have to ask you to leave um
sorry you know when they when they go
low we go lower i
this is the one thing though that i do
think hopefully
hopefully you know i mean linda graham
he's sacked up and i know
you weren't a fan of john mccain uh uh i
wasn't a huge fan of him either
not a fan of of lindsey graham generally
speaking mitch mcconnell we're still
trying to wonder if mitch mcconnell has
like
if it's if he has no chin or if it's an
optical illusion where he has
endless chins you know but it's now i'm
wondering this
about their balls i i wonder what do you
think it's because
here's my read on it okay they knew
kavanaugh
there were so many background checks
before he was obviously you know this is
going to be a public affair
i think this guy is was so spotless and
so clean
that they took this really personally
because they knew
uh what was afoot right yeah i think the
reason it blew up on him was you know
over a 40 48 hour period we basically
went from
he may have possibly held a girl down at
a party 35 years ago
to uh he was the leader of a high school
rape cult and he savaged this woman in
full view over family and friends
right like you know what i mean it just
it lapsed into incredulity like man if
only it left her at the bottom of a lake
this entire controversy
could have been avoided but i did like i
did how'd you like mitch mcconnell going
from mr turtle to uh ninja turtle
i i know i really you know i i don't
know
where this came from and i just think
they probably took this really
personally you know there were sort of
it's it's kind of like uh the patriot
where they're starting to pick off
generals and they're getting really like
these are not the rules of engagement we
must stand front line center to center
and
fire to each other offering no
territorial advantage i'm like i don't
know why you did war like that
so i i actually was a fan of the
guerrilla warfare but it seems at this
point like
the republicans are going really you're
just you're just naughty you're not even
gonna care that it's
just completely like you're having sweat
nick come out saying he's a gang rapist
this is where we are now
exactly although i would like at the
outset i'm from arizona i'd like to
apologize on behalf of my entire state
for jeff flake
yeah um i i know you could you could
apologize for true dough but we
we don't have all day no we do not have
all day i mean
honestly it's it's quicker just to put a
pillow over his face no i don't mean
kill him i don't mean kill him because
we're telling him
what i mean is just put a pillow over
her face so we don't hear him that's all
that's true yeah and if we don't hear
him for
ever more so so much better i um things
happen
things happen that's all we're saying
things
happen gosh he's so embarrassing i'm so
sorry you brought him up because i just
i just we this is the one show in a
while we didn't have a trudeau
clip yet and now it's still it's like
it's like it's like grapefruit juice you
just can't get rid of it it stays with
you all day
uh so okay so we can't predict it but
why
why do you think everyone is talking
about this this blue wave and do you
have you notice a shift
in in media the way they're covering it
at least going like there's going to be
a blue wave to
there there could there could be maybe
possibly
the size of a listerine cup here's a guy
beating up an old man in portland
no like my read on it is if if you look
at the data
in terms of how many seats are actually
up and how much like here's the thing if
everything goes right for the democrats
they actually get to keep the amount of
influence they have now right
that's all that happens right it's not
like they can even really
mathematically speaking storm the
bastille here really
right so it's once you you accept that
fact you realize
it's not so much that they're predicting
a blue wave as they
need a blue wave right because the other
default position
is they lose seats and probably lots of
them
yeah so it's it's hard to predict but i
would say
probably okay maybe one or two seats but
in the overall not a blue wave
understand this though no matter what
happens if one democrat wins they'll
call it a blue wave
right in the media okay even one wins
yeah just like if i get if one antifa
gets one shot in and a 75 year old and a
corolla they're like
okay we'll take the win we'll take it or
we can get it um
you're looking uh are you are you uh are
you feeling right are you tired
uh a little bit tired but i'm all right
i just met how you look tired from all
that
winning that's happening so uh
sorry dad joke walked into you but
winning so much and kanye we ate tacos
and watched
netflix channeling a little norm
mcdonald dad joke
a little little a little nor mcdonald a
little owen benjamin we have all this
going on in this show uh
and uh and usually uh people aren't
happy with it but you know what uh we
keep the lights on
all right that is the rage-aholic on
youtube which is different from your
twitter at
razorfist with a zero because yes you're
breaking all the rules when it comes to
branding or
you want to ensure that people do not
find you uh when can people look for
this video that you have though on the
blue wave because
your insight is always apparent that'll
be dropping in the next week we'll have
a full-on blu-ray
blue wave analysis i'll talk about some
of the things i mentioned here today but
go a little more in depth
okay oh yeah well great well listen if
uh if you want to come back and talk
about it uh
you're much more interested funny enough
and i think people don't understand this
about you
because you know you look like a crazy
person you're very you're very
educated on micro politics you really
are a political junkie you know i'm a
cultural guy
uh so i always learn a lot listening to
you even though i really just expect you
to you know
recite dio's holy diver or something
like wow wow that was very
that was pretty sensible all right thank
you mr fist we always appreciate it we
must go sir
godspeed thanks for having me
[Music]
only you can prevent retro arcade
machine sexual assault
by joining at lottoworthcrudder.com
today
mug club all kinds of mug all right
okay this could go off really quickly
but you guys
you guys have mugs you guys have been
around for a long time and honestly
really we we do appreciate uh yeah
having you around here i know the first
time you came in you're like well we're
not really conservative and then you saw
the mob on instagram you're like well i
guess
we're in it now you helped me come out
of the closet well
if nothing else but i do appreciate
tour.com and and really um
we do want you to go out and support
they have some tour dates coming up i
know you have some in texas uh
and what allows us to really actually
kind of build a platform for people so
that they can come out of the closet and
and not feel as though they're stepping
into this is mug club because
we know you've been completely
demonetized from youtube wonder what's
going on there
maybe well if johnny cochran was still
alive you might have had a case but
pretty much
better start doing those live shows live
with credit.com slash mug club 99
annually
uh 69 with your student veteran active
military you get the daily show all the
crtv lineup
and uh listen if you don't if you don't
let you know our main sponsor of course
is walther as well that's another way to
support the show you need a firearm
all we say is try the wall through we
don't really do the whole like oh god
it's the best of it listen
there are a lot of good firearms out
there walther has the balls to sponsor
the show
and i truly believe just try it try try
the walther see what happens
nine times out of ten you'll buy it uh
and with mug club it's like an
8.4 yeah but that's good yeah plus it
looks good no one here is really a
[Laughter]
mathematician
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
i have a basket that's called the why
did i jump in i don't know how to swim
dance
happened to me when i was younger jumped
into the water really didn't know how to
swim happened to me too
my grandpa jumped in full clothes and
everything but wait but
you said it happened to you no it
happened to me my grandpa jumped in to
save me oh i was like
the difference is you were 16. uh
it's i remember my dad was swimming
underwater in the breath and he looked
like a manta ray and i had seen someone
riding a man like a sea world so i
thought oh i'll jump on him and i
remember
first off he was he was gone by the time
i got into the water so i couldn't i
couldn't jump on him
and i just remember going i can't this
is i this is not something i can do i
can't do this thing
almost died wasn't as bad as the time in
the kayak so i've told that story for
reference see the archives thanks so
much to the hot twins
hodge twins tour.com uh of course
razorfist next week i know we've got a
crazy show we have we have ben shapiro
in for devil's advocate
ooh with uh skylar cherton they'll be
debating uh the merits and benefits of
socialism and uh i think we're gonna
have jordan peterson on soon um
daniel cormier i know dean cain it's a
it's a good time it's an exciting
and time do go and support the hot twins
um they're they're they they are kind of
you know they're being a little
nonchalant about it but the truth is
anytime you step
out they were fitness guys they were
they were um
they were i guess i don't know kind of
lifestyle i guess what you call because
it wasn't just fitness they did diet
fitness that kind of thing and then it
was also
a comedy mix and people realize they're
really funny so they started doing
comedy um but i always suspected that
they were more right leaning
i remember you the first time they're on
the show like listen you don't have to
say anything you're uncomfortable with
we always do that with a lot of these
guests sometimes there are guests on the
show where we don't even touch on
politics but
more often than not not always if
they're willing to appear on the show
you can take a wild guess
so i always thought well they're they're
former military they're entrepreneurs
uh family guys if you look at them uh
you look at uh you know they have wives
kids
good good stand-up guys actually they're
surprised very gentlemanly to actually
around
around women very much will surprise you
uh when they're on my mama
yes ma'am no ma'am um i don't say i
should say well you know it is
surprising but
i always thought okay they're probably
more right-leaning than they maybe even
necessarily
think and what transpired was they they
visited us on the show and then some
people just started for no other reason
the first interview wasn't political at
all they took a risk and then they saw
what happened it was kind of all right
okay screw you
and that's exactly that's what we were
talking about earlier right we were
talking about mob rule earlier that's
what happens that's the rebound reaction
the mob rule is not the rebound reaction
that's human nature
right this i hear a lot of people asking
this right how do we how do we get here
how do we how have we done so far
no we've always been here in some way
sometimes it's just a little more
apparent than others the rebound
reaction is not mob rule that's human
baseline because human beings are crappy
okay the rebound effect is the hodge
ones when they appear on this show it's
entirely
it's entirely benign and people say you
must be racists now
the rebound is okay screw you now we're
just going to actually look into this
conservatism thing
and become fans and that's why you
support them but let me tell you okay
let's get to human nature here for a
little bit before we get back to mob
rule
they took a risk and they appeared in
the show they've taken a lot of risks if
you look at them starting their own
youtube channel starting their own
clothing line
i respect that a lot they're primarily
two kinds of people in the world
risk takers and a lot of people are
gonna like this there are the risk
takers and the beneficiaries
now you think people who are willing to
take risks don't begrudge those
who don't they don't have a problem with
people who don't take risks the problem
arises
when the beneficiaries feel as entitled
to the spoils of the risk
as the person who took the risk in the
first place that's where we find
ourselves
right now that's when you get mob rule
when the unemployed antifa activist in
portland feels just as entitled to that
old man
stuff in the car and even even entitled
to his time
even though the old man is actually
spending that time traveling
to where he can work to create more
stuff and the person dragging him out
punching him feels just as entitled to
it
not everyone not everyone is on the left
but let me tell you something if you're
a socialist
you're probably an entitled person not
everyone in the democratic party but
everyone who's like oh maybe democratic
social entitled
i don't like you that's okay right now
listen i will tell you this i shouldn't
say that i don't like you
as far as to your soul as a person to
your core
but they probably don't have dinner
conversation with you there's no common
ground i'm a democrat you're any kind of
socialist
you're entitled it means you feel as
entitled to the guy in the car
as the just as the person outside of
that car dragging him out and beat him
up there
here's something else also i don't want
this to be misconception there are hard
workers
okay there are hard workers there are
risk takers they aren't necessarily one
in the same
you can be a hard worker you can be
disciplined you can be diligent but not
someone willing to incur the ultimate
risk
so it's not an insult middle management
higher positions of employment but not
business owners are filled to the brim
with these people
and there can be risk takers who aren't
necessarily hard workers are typically
all these people like loose cannons
kind of guy or girl you know right think
who takes needless risks without a
follow-through without a plan and so
they end up hurting themselves
right this idea that life should be
comfortable or easy is very new
it's very new in the realm of human
history that's a very new idea
uh you know to speak about kind of risk
takers a good example
at one point as i've discussed with him
owen benjamin
would take some needless risks be out
there like oh and you don't need to be
doing that for example but i've always
been kind of envious of owen if you see
him on stage
he goes into jazz mode and he just tries
new like he will do two hours and keep
going and just try new stuff and doesn't
care
if it works or not and then all of a
sudden the room will
the floorboards will shake with laughter
because he's taking risk after risk
after risk after risk
and i i haven't been you know i do some
of that in comedy but typically speaking
i i like to be prepared and i'm a little
meticulous if i'm doing stand-up
in the last few years and often that's
because there's a camera always on owen
doesn't care
he's willing to take that risk and
because of that if you see when owen
once he has his set once he goes okay
i'm no longer experimenting but this is
my
he kills he's a crusher because he's
willing to take that risk
we all benefit from it think of thomas
edison george washington
we all benefit from risk takers swimming
across
the body of water to where no man has
gone before
okay think of that concept a man swims
across
you have no idea what's there at that
point and you find paradise
but then the people who never made the
journey who saw that same
they looked down to that same
nothingness into the mist and they
demand that you trick back for them
because they feel just as entitled to
the new paradise found
and guess what the risk takers don't
want to give them a free ride
and the truth is you have to safeguard
your soul you have to safeguard your
soul against us because human
human nature we've talked about this
empathy is not envy human nature
is envy human nature is to want what
other people have
whether you've earned it or not sorry
guys i'm getting to my soapbox and
there's not a whole lot funnier
i'm pissed when i see someone getting
dragged from a car and beating up and
someone's like don't use the
m word i want to be i
you know if you ever daydream about
beating up the bully as a kid
i'm not gonna lie i daydream about being
that old man
in the car sometimes mutual combat state
it pisses me off and it pisses me off
when people try to go
gee golly i'm going to quote a bible
verse and i'm going to be a nice guy and
act as though oh
what let's find common ground unless
you're beating me out of my out of my
lexus
you think here's what you think people
at the top haven't figured this out that
human nature is to be envious
when you're young and you're stupid you
blame just the advertisers and the
corporations man
that's true they work with the
advertisers and by the way something
else to include politicians
because what are most politicians doing
they're just advertising ideas or in
today's instance of the democratic party
lack of them that's why i am honestly
i'm consistently amazed
that republicans or conservatives
everyone at all ever
because the left agenda the bernies the
nina pintas santa maria cortez
of the world what hillary clinton just
said about the reckless mobs
encouraging it that's the easiest sell
in the world
i'm shocked when a republican wins i'm
shocked when any candidate when a ted
cruz type person wins when someone wins
by saying
uh you know what i'm going to do less
because i want you to i want you to
trust in yourself
the whole kind of the left mocks the or
picking yourself up by your bootstraps
because it's an easy mock because most
people want to want to make an excuse
right it's an easy sell to say no no
it's not your fault it's the easiest
cell in the world
socialism don't believe me do this
mental exercise okay have you ever had a
time
where i don't know pick something right
now that you're really self-con you're
really self-conscious about pick
something maybe at some point in time
you probably have a memory of this
specifically
you stepped out kind of in faith and you
asked maybe like your wife or a loved
one or a family member
about this thing and kind of ask for
their feedback
but rather than regurgitate exactly what
you wanted to hear and some kind of
attempt to build up your self-esteem
they told you the truth
you ever have to happen to get pissed i
know i have
one example oh no you can you can barely
see that zit
were the words i were expecting to hear
before graduation
not what did you fall off your bike but
one was truthful
that's why the current leftist agenda is
the easiest cell in the world every time
someone asks
whether they're deserving of something
or not the answer is yes of course
am i just am i deserving of this man's
income yeah of course you are my
deserved even though i don't work in my
desert
yeah of course you're deserving of all
of it you need to safeguard your soul
against that because that's the easiest
cell in the world
and that's what they're selling right
now there's nothing sweeter on the
surface
than hearing exactly what you were
hoping to hear but that's not helpful
we see what happens with those people we
see what happens with those kids the
kids who never get the red
pen the kids are told they're wonderful
and pink sings to them telling them
they're perfect the way they are
they become portland antifa you know the
world is two kinds of people
this is a big reason for being where we
are there are risk takers
and then there are the beneficiaries and
a big part of this current conflict
is people refusing to do what you'll
need to do yourself
do it this week do it this weekend and
by the way if
those in charge they're playing on the
string that don't most of you don't do
it superbly they're hoping that you
don't so what is it that you need to do
the need to look yourself in the mirror
take your iphone put it in selfie mode i
don't care if you're a japanese tourist
that's probably what you're doing anyway
fine
just don't do it by the fountain while
i'm there with my wife
look yourself in the mirror grab your
selfie phone
and honestly assess which kind of a
person you are you a risk taker
or are you a beneficiary here's the good
news you can change it about yourself
you have or you can accept it it is not
necessarily a bad thing either or
because either is okay provided that you
don't feel entitled to the spoils of the
next guy without fulfilling
his or her requirements that's what once
you do that
when you look yourself in the mirror and
you say okay you know what i'm not a
risk taker but i feel like i deserve
what the risk taker created
that's when we get to where we are
that's when it becomes mob rule how did
it get this bad
how did it get this bad think of your
own think of who you are
think of your quiet thoughts when
nobody's watching when you can get away
think of when you were a kid and you
could get away with stuff
when you could take things that you
didn't deserve when you could take
credit that you hadn't earned
most people how do we get this far we've
always been here
because human beings are flawed
safeguard your soul
at least against the people in power
playing on that
and you know what don't try and find
common ground with them you don't have
to
you can be nice but you can also point
out that they're full of crap
that's how we're here with mob we've
always been here just encouraged it see
you next week
[Music]
you